[Music]
a mother accused of abandoning her child
on the las vegas strip speaks
to the i-team from jail you may recall
police asking for help to find miriam
ramos
the i-team's vanessa murphy talked with
ramos today to find out why she left her
child
and couldn't be found for weeks
mariam ramos repeatedly asking for her
child
the 26 year old is accused of abandoning
her three-year-old daughter at the wynn
on december 29th the next day metro
police released
the child's photo and this video
detectives identified ramos as the mom
she was arrested in california on
february 17th
[Music]
she says she moved from maryland to las
vegas and planned on staying with a
friend
when that didn't work out she says on
several occasions
she met men on plenty of fish so she and
her daughter would have a place to stay
she claims she connected with the man at
the wind who offered to take them in
ramos says she asked a woman to watch
her daughter for a few minutes in the
bathroom
and then went to put bags in an uber
she says the next thing she remembers is
waking up in california
she says she believes she may have been
drugged and sexually
a assaulted for a while ramos is charged
with child abuse or neglect
while the eye team cannot confirm the
version of events told by ramos
what we do know is she was missing for
50 days
decisions will have to be made right of
whether your daughter would be safe
moving forward
uh if you are both reunited do you
do you think she would be safe oh my god
i can't wait to see her
vanessa murphy 8 news now
after ramos daughter was found she was
taken to a child haven and placed with
the foster family